IMPEACHMENT.
THE IMPEACHMENT OF THE WEEK,
WITH NO SENATE TRIAL INSIGHT.
CONGRESSMAN MATT GAETZ PRESENTS
FLORIDA, ALSO ON THE JUDICIARY C
FLORIDA, ALSO ON THE JUDICIARY M
FLORIDA, ALSO ON THE JUDICIARY I
FLORIDA, ALSO ON THE JUDICIARY T
FLORIDA, ALSO ON THE JUDICIARY E
FLORIDA, ALSO ON THE JUDICIARY ,
FLORIDA, ALSO ON THE JUDICIARY A
FLORIDA, ALSO ON THE JUDICIARY D
FLORIDA, ALSO ON THE JUDICIARY H
FLORIDA, ALSO ON THE JUDICIARY E
JOINS US TONIGHT.
CONGRESSMAN, I SAID, I THINK ON
CHRISTMAS EVE, INSTEAD OF THE NO
RED SANTA TRACKER, NO RED OUGHT
TO HAVE IMPEACHMENT ARTICLE
TRACKER, HOW LONG IT IS
TAKING TO DO THE 73 FEET FROM
NANCY PELOSI'S OFFICE TO THE
SAID NO MARKS ON IT, SOMEWHAT
OVER THE JUNGLES OF NEW GUINEA
RIGHT NOW, IS SHE ACTUALLY GOING
TO BRING THIS THING HOME AND
DELIVER IT TO McCONNELL?
>> NANCY PELOSI APPEARS TO BE
LIMPING THROUGH THE BACK NINE OF
DELIVERING THE ARTICLES OF
IMPEACHMENT.
I THINK THE REGULAR FOLKS IN
THIS COUNTRY FROM ITS QUITE
INTERESTING TO SEE IN
IMPEACHMENT WITH FIRST, NO CRIME
AND A VICTIM, BUT NOW, NO
TRANSMISSION OF THE ARTICLES
THEMSELVES.
LISTENING TO THAT MONTAGE YOU
HAD OF THE MAINSTREAM MEDIA
GIVING NANCY PELOSI A PROVERBIAL
CAT BATH, IT JUST REMINDS ME
THAT THE REST OF US END UP STUCK
WITH THE HAIR BALL WITH THIS
SORT OF BIZARRE CIRCUMSTANCE
WHERE JUST WEEKS AGO, IT WAS
JERRY NADLER AND ERIC SWALWELL
SAYING THINGS LIKE NOTHING COULD
BE MORE URGENT THAN THIS
IMPEACHMENT, SWALLOW CALLED IT A
CRIME SPREE IN PROGRESS, AND NOW
CRIME SPREE IN PROGRESS, AND NON
CRIME SPREE IN PROGRESS, AND NOY
CRIME SPREE IN PROGRESS, AND NOP
CRIME SPREE IN PROGRESS, AND NOL
CRIME SPREE IN PROGRESS, AND NOS
CRIME SPREE IN PROGRESS, AND NOI
CRIME SPREE IN PROGRESS, AND NOH
CRIME SPREE IN PROGRESS, AND NOL
CRIME SPREE IN PROGRESS, AND NOS
CRIME SPREE IN PROGRESS, AND NOT
CRIME SPREE IN PROGRESS, AND NOE
ARTICLES OF IMPEACHMENT LIKE SOM
ARTICLES OF IMPEACHMENT LIKE SOE
DEMENTED, NONSANTA CLAUS, NOT
DELIVERING THE KIDS TO THE
CHILDREN.
IT'S STRANGE TO OBSERVE.
>> Mark: IT'S WEIRD, ISN'T IT?
THE PRESIDENT HAD A GOOD POINT
IN HIS TWEET, BECAUSE ACCORDING
TO JERROLD NADLER, DONALD TRUMP
IS A THREAT TO NATIONAL SECURITY
AND NEEDS TO BE REMOVED FROM
OFFICE.
SO WHY STICK IT IN THE BOTTOM
DRAWER AND DO NOTHING ABOUT IT?
>> WELL, IT DEMONSTRATES THAT
THIS WAS A POLITICAL PROCESS
FROM THE BEGINNING.
WE ARE ABOUT TO TURN OVER A NEW
YEAR, A NEW DECADE, BUT WE
CONTINUE TO SEE THE SAME
POLITICS, JUST BY NEW MEANS.
WHAT DEMOCRATS HAVE DONE AS THEY
ARE REALLY CHEAP IMPEACHMENT
PROCESS TO ANY DISAGREEMENT
ABOUT THE UTILIZATION OF
PRESIDENTIAL POWER, OR ANY
DISAGREEMENT, A PRESIDENT'S
DIFFERENT TYPE OF APPROACH TO A
PARTICULAR PROBLEM SET COME ALL
OF A SUDDEN BECOMES IMPEACHABLE.
WHEN THEY SAY IN THEIR COURT
FILINGS THAT THEY ARE NOT DONE
INVESTIGATING ARTICLES OF
IMPEACHMENT, I ACTUALLY BELIEVE
THEM, BECAUSE THEY HAVE NO
AGENDA FOR THE AMERICAN PEOPLE,
SO THEY ARE SUBSTITUTING THIS
PROCESS, THESE INVESTIGATIONS OF
IMPEACHMENT, FOR ACTUAL
LEGISLATION THAT MIGHT IMPROVE
THE LIVES OF THE PEOPLE THAT WE
ARE ELECTED TO SERVE.
>> Mark: DOESN'T THAT COURT
FILING REALLY GIVE THE GAME AWA
AWAY?
IT'S ONE CONTINUOUS
INVESTIGATION, JUST AS RUSSIA
LED INTO UKRAINE, AND MAYBE
TRUMP WAS ON THE PHONE TO SOME
GUY ENTER GIGA STAND, AND WE CAN
PUT THAT ON HOLD FOR NEXT WEEK'S
IMPEACHMENT.
BASICALLY, THEY HAVE BEEN DOING
THIS ACTUALLY SINCE BEFORE HE
WAS IN OFFICE.
IT WORKED ONLY IN THAT IT IS
SUPER INFUSED THE REPUBLICAN
BASE FOR 2020.
>> I CAN TELL YOU HERE IN THE
STATE OF FLORIDA, OUR SUPPORT
FOR PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS ONLY
INTENSIFIED WHEN WE SEE THESE
EFFORTS TO DELEGITIMIZE NOT ONLY
HIS PRESIDENCY, BUT OUR
POLITICAL MOVEMENT FOR A
POSITIVE AMERICA, FOR A NEWFOUND
SENSE OF POPULISM OUR COUNTRY,
AND NOW, I THINK YOU CAN LOOK
BACK TO THE TIME DIRECTLY AFTER
ROBERT MUELLER'S TESTIMONY,
WHERE THEY WANTED TO IMPEACH
JUSTICE KAVANAUGH.
THEY WANTED TO IMPEACH
BILL BARR.
IT'S LIKE THEY GOT IMPEACHMENT
FEVER AND THERE IS NO CURE.
LET'S TURN OVER THE CALENDAR IN
2020 AND AGREE TO LOOK THE WRECK
AND PEOPLE FIRST AND OUR
COUNTRY FIRST, NOT JUST
HAVE THE REVOLVING CARNIVAL OF
IMPEACHMENT WOULD NANCY PELOSI
AS THE RINGLEADER?
>> Mark: THAT MAKES TOO MUCH
SENSE, CONGRESSMAN.
YOU KNOW HOW IT IS, WHAT